so let me nip this one in the bud early
unless there's a weirdly specific alien
invasion that only abducts the we use of
the world nintendo are going to sell
some of their current gen console this
yeah but how are they going to sell an
awful lot of them well I may not be the
most qualified person to answer that
question but I'm going to give it a shot
anyway I'm just McDonald and you're
watching the gist my first suggestion
happens to play pretty well in to
Nintendo's court since it happens to be
something they're already working on
fixing I call it the explained the Wii U
to the consumer conundrum in may have
played host to a BuzzFeed article which
deemed it unbearably sad but the
brand-new Wii U advertisements of
earlier this year are bound to be a good
thing for the consoles future it's time
for a whole new Nintendo experience we
owners and newcomers alike it's time to
play Wii U sure it's kind of depressing
that over a year into it then tender
need to create a campaign reminding
gamers that the Wii U is not a gamepad
peripheral for the Wii but it's a
necessary temporary embarrassment to be
honest I was a part-time videogames
journalist when the Wii U came out and
it took me a really long time to figure
out what the damn thing was but now with
that groundwork sorted we can head on to
the marketing in terms of technical
tower the Wii U certainly doesn't really
stand up to the ps4 or the Xbox one even
though technically they're part of the
same console generation although it
certainly does have its merits merits so
good that Nintendo really should be
reminding you of them even though it
can't compete on graphical power
Nintendo has brought what it always
brings with its consoles innovation
while we're splitting hairs over the
minor differences between Sony and
Microsoft's offerings the Wii U is
basically incomparable and that's not
just in a bad way for example the
gamepad most games use it as a
can screen for additional game info but
the real advantage lies in playing games
on the pad without actually using your
usually in-demand
TV screen whilst this is mostly helpful
for families one big benefit that
everybody can agree on is backwards
compatibility that's the same feature
that those of us who are Playstation or
Xbox inclined have been moaning about
not being present on their latest
offerings and I'm excluding the still
relatively unclear state of PlayStation
now the Wii U is more than happy to play
your Wii games and to function with your
weak accessories as you can probably
tell there is a theme emerging with my
suggestions to Nintendo and they
basically involve telling the consumer
what they in for when they buy a Wii U
now this next one is pretty important
because while the games used to suck
they've actually gotten a lot better
gone are the days when the Wii U was
really just home to some malformed ports
and generic launch titles there are some
really enticing games on there now
because you know it's been out for ages
whilst it's up to Nintendo to make sure
gamers know what they can get it
involves the likes of Super Mario 3d
World Wind Waker HD Rayman legends and
Pikmin 3 there's probably even a game on
there that doesn't feature little
cartoon dudes probably but on that point
it is important to play to your
strengths and one of the issues Nintendo
experienced when they launched the Wii U
was that they weren't playing to theirs
Nintendo means family and family means
nobody gets left behind or forgotten or
something anyway a lot of people think
Nintendo should get a grasp on hardcore
gaming and the shoot-'em-up market but
personally I think that's a big mistake
that's not to say Nintendo doesn't make
difficult games they seriously do but
Nintendo makes the magic and nostalgic
universes that we drew money at time and
time again and that's pretty much where
they shine it's successful game
offerings are supported shooters or
zombie horror titles but the platformers
and games about charming and of morphic
dinosaurs and plumbers who don't seem to
have day jobs
that brings me down to my last point
sure drivers core first party franchises
and iterate on them with every entry but
that can't be the be-all and end-all
despite its rocky start the 3ds is a
great system and while some of you may
only be into it for Zelda and Pokemon
there's a lot of great games on it which
either use its unique hardware features
really well like Luigi's Mansion or just
straight-up great like fire emblem or
bravely default the way you would do
really well to try their best to follow
in these tracks and not simply rest on
the laurels of Mario and Zelda seeing
more enticing exclusives like the
wonderful 101 and Bayonetta 2 for
example is going to do wonders for the
publisher in terms of getting Wii U's
off shelves and not in a towards the
garbage sense well I agree that the Wii
U hasn't had the most steady of launch
periods I certainly don't think that
it's a write-off then again I may not be
the most qualified person to comment on
such a thing so if you think the Wii U
is doomed or if it can be safe do let me
know in the comments down below or my
Twitter where I'm at just McDonald's
I'll be back again next week but until
then thanks for tuning in
you